i had a cia agent on
last week mike baker i think his name is
michael baker
and interview hasn't come out yet but
he'll come out here soon and i was
speaking to him i said
a question for you on who is the best
you know secret agency you know
intelligence agency in the world of
course we got cia mi6
assad uh mossad all these other ones
that are out there
which one would you say is the best one
is it israel is it ours is it uk's
and he said it's us's agency that's
better than everybody else
of course you have to say that because
that's who you represented you were part
of it for nearly 20 years
but here's a question for you how
superior is china's
intelligence agency today because that
name is never
dropped amongst the other mi6 is china
kind of looking around saying please
don't put us on that list because we
kind of like the fact that none of you
guys know
how far ahead we are of you how much
more advanced we are of you
because all the three names you're
talking about they're innocent we're
willing to go places
that they're not willing to go how would
you describe to the average person
you've been
you've lived in china i think twice one
time you went there as a in when you
were in the air force and then you came
back and you went back again and you
were
a general in the air force so you've
been studying the topic of china for
quite some time matter of fact when you
were the senior director one time
at the national security council you got
up to kind of give a briefing to
everybody about what really
why china is really the biggest enemy
and you have mcconnell sitting on one
side biden's sitting on one side one's a
republican
whose wife has got family over there
with the big construction company and
you got biden obviously with his son
having a relationship with china and
then six months later they fire you
uh maybe you triggered something when
you said that but how strong
is their secret you know intelligence
agency against all the other ones in the
world
well i think it it's a it's a strength
of their system
and and it's a fact that everything and
everybody
is responsive to requests by the chinese
communist party if you're a student if
you're
if you run a company i don't know if you
remember
but you know if you're a billionaire in
china you can just be disappeared
uh you know look at jack ma look at you
know
um a bunch of other billionaires that
have basically find
found themselves you know out of power
so
their system is one in which the party
requires people to do things
uh and and doesn't take no for an answer
and so
um you know we think of okay the if you
get hired by the ca
cia that's one thing if you're if you're
running
a company you know you're not part of
the government you're not supposed to be
doing anything
funny business uh the chinese communist
party doesn't see the world that way and
in fact they
enlist everybody the entire population
in one way or another they either use
indoctrination to basically
you know give a party line but they also
use
the fact that you know uh companies
chinese companies are global they use
the fact that
the the market of china is an incredible
draw
for other companies so one of the things
that just recently happened i don't know
if you saw
uh shanghai expo a girl gets up on top
of a tesla and starts jumping up and
down and saying the brakes are bad and
then i got bad service from tesla what
happens
so they did do they do they smash that
protest
you remember this is a country that
killed ten thousand people in tiananmen
square no
no they videotape it and it goes on
national media all over china
and then it's picked up on social media
don't buy tesla cars
buy chinese electric tesla's the number
one selling electric vehicle
in the market in china now they're down
27 percent
cri it's falling like a brick what are
they doing there what was that about you
know so
who is who is the target ultimately of
that attack the target
i would say of that attack is elon musk
and the target of that attack is not so
much tesla
i believe as it is spacex why
spacex is building starlink what could
what could starling do starlink could
could transmit
into the mainland china and provide
internet to the people of china i think
that's one of the things that the
chinese communist party is concerned
about
and so they basically want to send a
lesson to elon musk
and now you know he's trapped he's
basically
sold the market on the fact that he's
gonna have all these sales in china
they've got him they've they've hooked
him and and this is what they do
i've seen it over and over and over
again what they wait till they got you
they got you hooked and then they start
to
turn the screws and you don't even know
what they're trying to get
right now and then i saw a report you
know the you know officials at tesla are
trying to figure out
what do they even want they they may not
even tell you what they want
um until you know you they they've let
you kind of swing a little bit so
this is the problem with the chinese
communist party is it's not just there
they have impeccable impeccable um
intelligence services because they
collect so much data on us and
and have ai that they that they run in
fact you know they
say they want to become the saudi arabia
of data for their ai their ability to
collect
intelligence on us from your smartphone
everything around you
so they have an incredible machine that
is
merged with their commercial sector in a
way that
that quite frankly we don't understand
and we don't we
we don't look at jack ma and say hey
jack ma is not only working for the
chinese communist party he's also
working for alibaba
so you know you don't you didn't even
know he was a communist member
until he came out and said so and then
you know of course they they
they deposed him from his role as a ceo
so
this is a system it's a far far more
um dangerous system than we've ever
faced
because we've allowed it to come into
our midst
so so the concern is if elon musk does
what he wants to do
and he provides free internet for the
folks in china they may be able to get
on facebook twitter create those kind of
accounts
where folks around the world can really
see what's going on in china rather than
being able to control
and silence everyone in china is that
kind of what you're saying
that's what i'm saying
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye